I'd love to start at the beginning but
i'ma start at the end about the very
last shot that we saw how did that come
about and why was it important for Tommy
that it was in the film so that scene
was not supposed to be in there Ascott
you did not write that scene earlier I
definitely wrote a version I worked
really but not in the original draft not
in the original draft Tom whatever we
wrote Tommy was like yeah ma I'm not
saying any of that okay well back it up
I had to get Tommy's life rights and his
big point in his contract was that he
have a scene in the movie and that was
fine I mean honestly like I thought that
would be cool like a little Hitchcock
nod and you know if he's in the
background like there you know there was
a sequence that got cut out of the movie
where Greg's character shoots this movie
that's maybe even worse than the room
called retro puppet master we shot this
scene in Romania and I kept trying to
you know suggest to Tommy that yeah
maybe maybe you want to be in the
Romanian scene he's like nah know how to
be opposite James I thought to be in the
scene when James and he didn't know he
didn't read his contract very well and
it said we just had to shoot it we
didn't have to put it in the movie so he
shows up we didn't know what he was
gonna do and he was actually really
sweet
he said he three days before he texted
me and he saw I want my character to be
named Han Rae I'm like okay fine hunter
aid it's fine
and and then he sent me a photo he was
obviously in LensCrafters there were
rows of glasses behind him and he had
glasses on and he's like what you think
of glasses for character I don't like to
great they're great for hun right that
yeah I can't tell it to you I can tell
you that mustache yeah and then he drew
it drawn a mustache on like with big pen
like a little soul patches only and he
said if you like mustache I draw it on
batterer when we shoot
and I was just like I mean what kind of
movie does he think we're making anyway
I was like look I'll get you a fake
mustache and whatever and so obviously
he's like trying to you know hide who he
is but like it's impossible right and
when I watched that scene I'm like
surprised I actually was trying to make
it work you know my editor put in the
first assembly and we watched it were
like okay haha get that get that out of
there and anyway we had shot and then we
were so proud of the recreations of the
room scenes that we had done which were
originally only gonna be used in the
premiere scene but we so proud of our
work we're like what we need to do a
side-by-side for the credits and we but
we had not we hadn't negotiated for the
room footage and so we had to go back to
him and negotiate for that and during
that negotiation he's like well ha yeah
how am i how much scene and somebody was
like it's not in there and he is like
well you want my you want my footage got
to put my scene in at first we were like
oh no what are we gonna do and then we
realized we could do like a Marvel tag
and it would be perfect for the
superfans and and would be awesome so
worked out I think there but for the
grace of God go a lot of filmmakers that
Tommy wanted to make a movie he believed
in himself he was going to overcome
every obstacle and do that so is that
kind of the spirit of the adaptation to
not be judgmental but to celebrate the
spirit of Tommy fighting this fight
against all odds yeah that absolutely
was I mean what we we were introduced to
the room via the memoir I read about
five or six chapters all I knew was the
Billboard from living here and and I
stopped reading and I said I got to
watch this thing and I watched it the
worst way you can which is on your
laptop by yourself and my writing
partner he was like should I watch it
and we were like you know what maybe you
shouldn't watch it don't watch it we're
not writing a story about like a movie
we're writing story about these people
and what they did and we really related
to them we were we were you know kids
from the East Coast who dreamed of
making movies that's all we ever wanted
to do
we didn't know how to do it we didn't
know that it was possible to do it and
it was one of those sort of super
inspiring
I am stories of these guys were just
when did it and they didn't just make a
movie they made a movie the people are
quoting and seeing on repeat and and
still talking about almost 15 years
later which honestly it's like it we're
worse envious it's incredible and so
there was never any derision and there
was never any let's make fun of this our
biggest fear was that like when you guys
sent us the book James and and seth
rogen his producing partners we didn't
know you guys and we were like well
we're not if they want to do like a
shot-for-shot remake or if they want to
do a you know like a this is the end
kind of comedy about like a bow thing
your comedy about moviemaking we were
probably the wrong people for that we're
not we're not funny that's for sure but
when we all sat down and talked about it
it was like you know let's we want to
try to do something like Ed Wood or
Boogie Nights or you know Sunset
Boulevard or any of these movies that we
all kind of love and we saw it that way
from the beginning James I want to
understand the math of what it was like
on set so you were directing yourself as
Tommy directing the other actors in the
room in which you're also acting so how
do you get through clearly what it is
you are on a given day and are you
directing ask Tommy or as James he was
beard yeah yeah I was weird uh it's
right i I've talked about this to a
bunch of audiences and nobody nobody has
come up with another example of a movie
and I didn't realize it when we were
doing it but of a movie where the
director was acting in it playing a
director who's also acting in his own
movie and then stayed in character when
he directed now yeah so I'm sure it was
bizarre and weird and the more we talked
about it and I think about it I'm like
yeah that was kind of that's kind of it
was an adjustment period for everyone I
I got used to it a little bit quicker
than most just because he's my brother
and there's not much he can do that
surprises me anymore but like
Seth Rogen took him a full week to get
to the point and just laugh in his face
every time he looked at him but it just
I mean honestly it all put pro than so
obviously exactly but it James you said
Oh James are you Tommy or you James who
are you now it wasn't as black and white
as that it was just something eventually
it just became this weird meta thing
that all just kind of put us on the
right have you guys would address me as
Tommy I didn't ask for that but I think
you a might
I've forgotten Tommy I have looked got
you were like a handsome dude like it
was we forgot what you look like
whoever tells the best story yes I'm a
good-looking guy on set oh my god
whoever tells the story that like the
one beauty of course yes of course one
day on set you didn't have to do the
makeup literally only one day and that
day you showed up as you're this and
we're and talk normal and the next day
you showed up in the thing again and the
van pulls up and you got out of the van
and you go where was everybody yesterday
as if like and like that's that's the
kind of thing that was so fun and what a
wild experience we have dave is it
inevitable that as you're making a movie
about a friendship about Tommy and
Greg's friendship and their relationship
that you think about your relationships
your brother and where it mirrors your
story about two guys who want to make a
movie together and where your stories
overlap good question so just going back
this so this is the first time we've
worked together in a substantial way and
that's that's my fault I was when I was
first starting out I I did make a
conscious decision to distance myself
from him work wise just because I wanted
to pave my own path and just do my own
thing and then it just felt like the
right timing like the right project we
understood this dynamic really strongly
we did we did some videos for the
website funnyordie.com
about ten years ago where he plays
a crazy acting teacher and I'm his
student who looks at him like he's a
crazy man and so and it was actually the
exact dynamic that we have in this movie
and so I think you can talk about this I
think that's why when you read the book
you immediately knew that we could we
could do this together and in regards to
just their friendship and then our
relationship as brothers what do you got
I came out to Hollywood alone and then I
after 12 years I went to NYU for film
school for directing and I I would say
to myself for I think maybe even out
loud like man I would just wish I had a
close collaborator you know I just want
my own Coen brother you know that's a
and and I didn't realize you know I got
my own Franco brother that I can work
with and I think Dave's a great actor
he's an amazing actor and I and I had
yeah and I had wanted to work with him a
few times before this and he had said no
so when I when I was reading the book
you know often you read something as you
know the source material and you you
just get a feeling you know the hairs
rise on the back here neck and and often
you'll get images or scenes will pop out
you're like dude that's the kernel like
I just want to recreate that and then it
kind of builds from there and the things
I got here where I like are you how to
way into Tommy I knew I just I knew I
could get in there I understood it
somehow or intuitively and I knew that I
wanted a four for Greg so I remember
telling one of the producers Vince Jolla
vet like hope Davie doesn't say no to
this one we can can you ask him me I
don't want him to say no and he and he's
like you know you ask him he's your
brother it'll mean a lot like all right
and I mean I guess I tried to act casual
I was like Dave wants you watch you know
watch this movie the room
and yeah and then so then I had not seen
it and so like Scot I I watched it alone
for the first time in a hotel room and I
would not recommend that to anyone just
because you you want to watch it with a
group so you can turn to people and and
be like what the [ __ ] is going on so I I
finished that viewing just feeling very
unsettled and not really knowing how to
feel but then so I guess I didn't
immediately say yes but then I went to
one of the midnight screenings where
people are you know yelling at the
screen and throwing spoons and I
immediately understood the cult status
of it and since then we've we both seen
the room more than any movie in
existence which you know there's
something to be said about that James
Scott and Dave thanks for sure thank you